previously on the vlog I'm gonna be
running the very first crash course
outside of England in Edinburgh this way
so if you want to come down to Scotland
Edinburgh it's gonna be incredible
there's gonna be magic going on property
- investors doctor at UK gets at
Edinburgh the magical man you won't
regret it
[Applause]
[Music]
type wrist educators person of the most
energy width surround yourself with
great people baby run fast and don't
stop at the
[Music]
[Music]
guys my name is Samuel Letts I'm Michael
Byrne this guy is absolutely killing it
in property he's been on the crash
course twice he's basically taking my
systems and applied them all over the
world all over the world you may have
seen him on TV he's been all over TV you
may have seen him on winners on a
Wednesday
he's got properties where you've got
property senri Edinburgh Newcastle
Ireland everywhere so what we're gonna
do today is we're gonna be going inside
some of his properties show you exactly
how much money is making giving you a
tour so let's go let's do this
I like this one in the peak times in the
French pencil this 104 5500 I look at
this um sweet major-league here
I mean I love skills you know foot and
apart from that and or pair you have
different rules and regulations then
down south of the UK as well called its
class the different countries
essentially and when I was doing some
research one of the main things in the
fender it's one of the secrets things
but there is only a one month chance
agreement leasing spot okay yeah so when
I was coming in I was offering 12 at
least two landlords so basically he I'm
just trying to fight tenants every every
two or three months territory over
clients for a landlord that's help and
so for all this kind of coming in I was
like what would you do if I was to offer
you and one month or an 18 month or a
24-month lease this was rented I'm a
landlord somebody's rented this for me I
could rent this from mult
no no attachments you know just subtle
ease that's it one more turn to
agreement we can I invented this
Scottish business lease yeah it also
exists but I said guys guess what I've
got
guess what I've got and then I came in
everybody understand like I was like
I've got this lease that says I'm gonna
take this property off your castle free
from least a year and that was it we do
structure and then we've other people
the people who don't don't want to
commit to a month might want to stay for
a night or a week in your Katy to those
which was a premium exactly so what kind
of profit on average this one here
parameters to tell tickets 2100
[Music]
so it's amazing about my life is no
matter which country are going whether
I'm in in the UK whether I'm overseas I
always have students that are killing it
in property using the principles which
actually kind of work pretty much
globally now I'm in Edinburgh I hooked
up with my mum Michael
this dude is killing it hello guys oh
you know and his property business is
funding in beautiful nice car that you
recently bought we've just been going
inside some of his houses this is one of
his service departments not this one
today actually go in today but we've
been going out you've got like six in
this area yeah so we've been going
around the apartment in a month and
honestly like this how much how much
profit you making justice in this
product much way on this one roasting
2002 to 2200 month and he doesn't even
own it he just controls it and put down
3,000 pounds put down 3,000 pounds
controls it I'm going around the houses
this is real-life stuff so I'm stoked
got six of these in the area setting up
a spa here yeah got smashing so the team
from Newcastle working over here as well
we're just doing it it's happening every
day we're dream and this guy is the
ultimate example of someone who takes
massive action has massive courage but
it also gets the trainer you've come
into the crash tomorrow yeah for the
third time towards home crash course he
went to Manchester crash course he went
to the crash course in London now he
does not go to a crash course and not
come out after meet people motivated and
not work who cannot work out there go
and get all that information now is it a
crash course in Edinburgh and people are
saying oh it's too far three hours just
get there man take three hours of your
life you got a tape thing you got to
take massive action if you want to get
massive resource like this so respect
let's go to the next property matter
service too
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
here
[Music]
between Virginia so if you're not
supposed to I'm so blown away by Michael
I need to take my property crown off now
and then give it to Michael I think or
something
[Laughter]
[Music]
love it surround yourself with great
people daily Michael top three keys to
success in business Oh crash course
anywhere in the UK or oil it's gonna be
there this year and listen to ears one
mouth and listen to what listen to
everything
- where's one mouth yeah talk less
listen more okay I'm and team up with
this guy I can't argue with that I can't
argue with that I would say three keys
to success number one take massive
massive action number two do due
diligence sometimes just sometimes
sometimes doing a deal isn't necessarily
a good thing if it's a bad deal that's
why it's great to have people like you
know Rob Rochelle people around to
crunch numbers machine machine C machine
and then number three I would say get
good people around you if you've not got
friends who are doing well then you're
probably not going to do well either so
get around people that are successful
get around people that want to see you
do well and take risks don't be afraid
to take those big risks you know take
risks educated risks so Michael you know
is killing it but also Michael you met
so many good people yeah we have and
you've joint ventures with people on the
Kratt your first courses yeah yeah
Michael he's like a networking machine I
see him he keeps coming to the crash
courses he's networking with people
who's doing joint ventures so we're in
Edinburgh now and the deals that we're
looking at there you're their joint
ventures with you and people that you
met at the crash course literally just a
couple months ago yeah introduced yeah
yeah bro seen these guys were at the
crash course that we were you guys in
long enough and I just got on trade and
I was like to know what what we need to
do is work in terms of volume and unless
you know that's why whole bakery doesn't
have to be that slice of cake let's get
the whole bakery in and we started the
reason that Michael wanting to work with
Rob and the Machine is because of their
energy on the day like you I've seen the
footage man I see the footage you'd be
like crazy energy I always say the
person who has the most energy wins so
these guys have got massive energy so
I'm not surprised to see the friggin
winning
[Music]
small business yeah which is making a
load of money
let's make so you spending all your time
running around managing renter ends
probably wouldn't make a lot of sense
for you know so what you're doing is
you're teaming up with people yeah that
you like they're really good at finding
deals I mean you're putting down the
money and enjoy measurement that
basically yeah for me the time obviously
what I've learned is that time is of the
essence and yeah for me if I was to do
this on my own this platform stuff
manage everything for you so we don't
even need managers now essentially and
what what I what I love to do is I I was
at a point last year where there was
nothing really for me because I've
reached what I felt my max potential in
revenue or financial you know stainless
and I was kind of like well you know
what else do we kind of do and then I
just kind of wanted to start helping
really helping people and just seeing
the people that really wanted to work
for it not just the hell banging around
the people the people that really had
something to give you help utilize their
mental tools and so that's when I
started to kind of work with the people
that I found so much passionately with
you working with robear Shane Robert
O'Shea and Abey Abey is coming here now
he's on his train he's coming right to
us so it's amazing but the team like
that the team that we've selected and
I'm working with and the wanting is that
they're energy driven they're motivated
they work their work ethic is their
belief in what the deal is so big yeah
overpowers even what they get in terms
of properties it's not about that and
it's not about that for me it's not
about that for you island and it's about
now being able to pass that on and
obviously love what you're doing
you know and it gets to that point and
I'm in that transition period now of
where I'm only starting to learn to
engage or people as I grew up with the
belief of you need to be enclosed with
your money you need to keep it all you
need to keep everything you need to keep
your mind your knowledge and coming to
the course and stuff it learns you that
you can actually move quicker and then
people you know the long ball game is
for me is for my team to be successful I
reach the goals at standards and achieve
their dreams for me working with you the
people at the moment and the financial
goal is that we can potentially hit by
the end
this year for the end of this year but
for half a million reasonably and in
what we've done just with the despise
the corporation that joint ventures with
the team and its really achievable for
us to hit those targets my secret goal
was to actually work closely with a core
team so I called the core four and then
they're like the four people I would
select from and I set up another group
well Dave was in there and Dave hasn't
really been as connector on Bob as much
but that's okay yeah so it's wherever I
felt was importing and that's who was
kind of worth quit so massively and
we've traveled to each other with water
in our deals
see how it's felt over what he's found
is another spy in the Midlands and we
just found another spot
oh babe our 37th spa spa and so where
are you going to do that as well so
potentially and spa in the right
location with the right the right size
capacity has to be two and a half there
that's work but and if they want the way
home on my in Ireland you're looking at
the potential of just under two million
per year that's amazing this one and it
goes no you probably get about 90 210 on
weekend good location yeah and you
obviously enjoy your garden and you
making a profit how much the guys know
the figures I'm not I think it's in a
region of about a thousand thousand a
month proper you know so many of these
thousand pound a month profit per house
you don't need a lot you don't need a
lot of properties if you're making a
thousand panem of profit and you don't
even need to own them so it just sounds
too good to be true but people are doing
it I'm doing it these guys are doing now
I've got hundreds of success gyms doing
it every single week on winners
Wednesday you'll see someone doing this
kind of thing so it is real
[Music]
I'll begin however it's dog-eat-dog it's
ready man then
come in guts this is the master bedroom
he knows well it's like a courtyard just
like another breakfast area for the
summertime
it's really really nice I love this one
and we've got an ensuite baby and this
one it's not like too much the bedrooms
this one has storage it's not an ensuite
full of quite dated spaces really nice
this one sold quite properly because of
the LED lights in the ceiling as well
this one would be classed as a luxury
property and its location its central
and this one is right in the heart of
central and crimson Street isn't Jason
to this street George the street that's
your shopping district and your night
life as well it's all about the location
guys so whenever you're going for
property key is location location comes
first the condition of the property
doesn't even rate it doesn't matter it
could be set on anything if it's in the
right location I've got really bad
properties are in a key location and
making a lot of money you know it's its
location is everything three years
second - location I would advise the I
suppose the condition of the property so
luxury will tell all year round
and with the location and luxury tlf
bill for highly recommended so this came
as is the only thing that I put into
this one of the TV I recommend putting a
big television and Arne of your
properties as big as you can possibly
fit in
it just makes such a big difference pull
it up here just about pull up beds this
one sleeps 8 the modern reform refit
kitchen the main thing that sells this
property this is one of my most
expensive problems me
this one its location which is down this
tree on the left is called princess tree
which is the top occasion in Edinburgh
the trans are all central everything
comes into here so this is shamrock this
is key location where the heart of ever
ever really be on arrival or full of
success I've got my team ever hear how
he would be happiest two figures ma'am
so these are gonna do I'm just gonna
give a quick breakdown of how it's
possible that we came into this property
and it's an agency that I kind of got
reconnected with already as well from
one of the other properties that we had
I asked them to have any court once they
gave you this one with the same landlord
so once you get that from the door and
you've already got it and so this one
costs 1,850 per month and it makes
overdue capacity this one will make
profit about 2200 paramours what's that
work every year and just all 25,000 per
year king baby okay so that's the
portfolio tour we've been right I even
remember how many houses it's all kind
of in a bit of a blur now but I will say
is I've had a fantastic day thank you to
Michael for showing me around his
properties have you enjoyed the day I
felt absolutely amazed there thank you
so much what would be your words of
inspiration encouragement advice to
anyone watching this is thinking oh my
gosh I want to get some properties like
that what should they go down to ask you
know the fears what is what's closed
everybody off to just overcome the fear
and make them that reality it does
happen and like I've said earlier on
there's been so many kind of deluded
people and platforms as people are
trying to sell everything to everybody
and it's a shame because this one
actually works if it's up here put it
into action and it'll work for you you
know you just got to do it fantastic so
take action get the knowledge believe in
yourself believe in the system thanks so
much man I appreciate you I'm super
proud of you as well it's really
inspired by we're doing so I hope to see
more over the coming year guys if you
enjoyed the video please don't forget to
smash the like button drop a nice
comment below I'm sure Michael will read
every single one if you're not a
subscriber yet subscribe right here and
if you want to see more videos like that
you can do that
right above his face it is is alright
guys peace out see you next time
see that is a snake just talking can't
look bad once you start walking
but all we really need
you